v
enfin comme ils fabriquent les cinq
instruments principale qui fait partie
du maloya sadia le rouleur le caillou
mlle bob le piquer avec le sati et ces
instruments sont entièrement monté
fabriqué dans mon atelier
auparavant les tbonds comme un passe
temps mais après depuis un an et demi
maintenant traîner ça y fait à mon
activité principale se dit ami fait ça
tous les jours
ben le bob il faut compter 1 ère
mi-temps avec la décoration le
vernissage
c'est l'instrument le plus facile dans
le maloya fabriquer vos passions fétiche
à la tête par un résonateur c'est tout
mais ce à dire après c'est selon les
ouvertures on va faire dans la calebasse
va partir la ronde de haut niveau la
sonorité le kayamb on sait il est
composé avec des fleurs canne à sucre
des donna des grains qui a eu des dents
et qui fait le sont quand même les
poules et les anciens mandats c'est à
dire le montady ligaturer les tiges de
fer jamais attachés sur le support avec
de la ficelle fin juillet ou de
septembre
la clp est comme ça a fait mon stock de
flou cannes dans les grins qu'on fera
pareil ça c'est toute l'année miramas
camp mais ça va donc changer la vie avec
la route miramas pour faire du stock
c'est du montage méfaits de la
rénovation il fait du sessad pour
préparation pour quoi rouler à la pointe
se crée de façon si on veut avoir une
bonne base ce niveau laisse une pause
d'environ 4 mm 5 mm c'est la lnah les
meilleurs bars sur sa des peaux fines
défaut metz on aura un son aigu et le
sont recherchés pour rouler c'est la
base
des fois on a des antilles surtout des
vues qui encourage quiconque josh et où
il trouvait à dubaï fait plaisir et
moins et c'est un besoin savoir faire
ils abandonnent paris continue elle est
toujours et agréable et gaillard camp où
on en fabrique on voit des artistes qui
jouent avec des instruments ils
valorisent les instruments ce voyage
aller ils donnent ali un autre dimension
il donne le sérieux à l'instrument et
qui donne aussi la possibilité d'avoir
une clientèle futur
je m'appelle madame violette darier
j'habite mare à poule d'eau
je fais la tisane a pas y toucher c'est
ma mère qui m a transmis le savoir faire
et maintenant je fais ça poids passion
pour m'amuser occuper un petit peu le
temps dans le chou tout est beau on
cueille la tige pour faire les chapeaux
après il d'abord il ya la patate chaude
qui est au fond dans la terre après il
ya les brèches ou aprilia le chouchou il
ya le cornichon le gâteau chouchou et si
la confiture de chercheurs sur la paille
chaud il faut pas
elle gagne de la pluie parce qu'elle est
de viennoise et mais on ne porte pas de
la pluie c'est juste pas le soleil pour
la beauté il faut partir dans la nature
au bord des ravines des routes on prend
les tiges un peu dur en coupe en deux on
enlève la fibre est dedans on met dans
de l'eau on met à tremper pendant deux
jours ou bien une journée jusqu'à ce
qu'elle devienne deviennent blanches
après on met au soleil et aux du moment
que ce seul ace a cherché à peu près une
demi journée après là on peut commencer
à travailler pour apprendre il faut à
peu près une semaine après il ya le
montage et à la finition
il faut avoir un peu plus de technique
alors on peut faire des chéquiers on
peut faire des bijoux de peau jesse mdd
porte des lunettes
on peut faire pour mettre dedans j'ai dû
dans pour les baptêmes
voila je viens de faire une association
créée une association c'est parce qu'il
ya une forte demande de la population
des réunionnais des gens extérieurs qui
veulent apprendre le métier
il ya beaucoup de demandes des gens des
réunionnais qui veulent la mode et ce en
métropole et même d'ailleurs la paille
shushus m'a ouvert les portes d'abord
j'ai rencontré monsieur michel jarry qui
nous à rouvray un peu les portes bientôt
vallée au vietnam il pouvait faire une
exposition est peut-être ailleurs aussi
montréal soit d'envoyer chapeau à la
reine elizabeth pour avoir
si elle met la main dessus ne serait-ce
qu utiliser une fois